my Secretary's in charge of my finances
and she obviously screwed this up it's
not my fault your credit cards are maxed
I've get out of here are your mom's
really pissed what our needs insurance
for to protect your valuables you sub
dog insurance wow you're really gonna
make some money on that violin I don't
have no violent for Mickey Prohaska I'm
here to install security system left
some paperwork in there an opportunity
to turn life around I see you found your
paperwork is about to take a turn for
the worse I came over to check on the
house no no this is your fault huh
you're as guilty as me keep your mouth
shut er I'm gonna take you down with me
you got it you're not just stand there I
need five grand right now I don't have
that kind of cash
well I think you better get it by monday
keep your mouth more cash today I'm in
real trouble here oh you gotta believe
me why you lie all the time I have a
famous violin what starts out looking
like an easy score can turn out to be
anything it's simple anything you feel
like you need to tell me I don't think
this is my violin why is everybody
looking for the violin it's stolen
there's a lot of corruption out there
but you think you're gonna sell this on
your own you're sadly mistaken good
singing I think I have something you may
want i'm working at a very big deal
you're not trying to pin this on me are
you
I'll be watching your every move
you